tout près de l'épave du plus gros avion
du monde le ministre ukrainien de la
défense vient récompenser ces militaires
l'aéroport d'hosto mail dans la région
de kiev avait été occupée dès le début
de la guerre l'ukraine en a repris
contrôler le peuple de kiev prie pour
vous et pour nous et que nous les
dégagements de notre pays du fond de mon
coeur merci gloire à l'ukraine les
célébrations se font dans le calme car
cette victoire a été obtenue au prix de
lourdes pertes
je ne peux pas vous dire comment cette
heure
ce n'est pas la victoire pour l'instant
c'est
ce sera la victoire quand ils sont
partis nous avons tellement peine tout
près de là de nombreuses villes ont été
totalement détruites dimanche au moins
400 corps de civils ont été découverts
dans la région de kiev mais ce quartier
semble avoir évité les pires atrocités
les russes étaient ici ils sont allés
dans chaque maison je ne sais pas
vraiment ce qu'ils cherchaient
depuis le 4 mars nous n'avons plus
d'électricité ni d'eau ou de gaz donc
nous devons cuisiner dehors ici
pas d'électricité signifie pas
d'information certains soldats se charge
désormais de les transmettre
des russes disent qu'ils vont prendre le
contrôle des régions de donetsk de
lougansk
où qu'il y aurait une escalade là bas
oui c'est inévitable mais nous sommes
prêts il affirme avoir choisi de se
retirer de cette région nous les avons
tellement con bardet qui n'était même
plus capable de combattre ici cette
colonne militaire a été détruite il ya
trois semaines
les corps des soldats russes sont encore
éparpillés autour de ses occupants
rouges ont tenté d'utiliser cette route
pour se rendre jusqu'à kiev en passant
par hear pin nous avons fait exploser ce
pont ainsi que les soldats rouges
présents les membres de la garde
nationale tout comme leur véhicule il
c'est ici que nous avons stoppé
l'avancée des russes vers kiev les
ukrainiens affichent leur fierté et leur
soulagement d'avoir libéré la région de
kiev des troupes russes mais ils
redoutent une chose que les russes
souhaitent prendre rapidement leur
revanche